what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a lot of Spider-Man
news to talk about we could have a
possible release date for Spider-Man 4
and in turn we could know a little bit
about when to expect Spider-Man 5 and 6.
Venom 3 also has an update and we have
news about Miles Morales and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe both for Tom Holland
Spider-Man films but also for across the
spider-verse and we do also have a
little bit of a clarification about what
Spider-Man's role is going to be in
Avengers Kang Dynasty so lots of big
Spider-Man love today also big thank you
to my partners over at G fuel for
sponsoring this video and keeping me
energized many of you know I've been
partnered with G fuel for a very long
time they have a lot of really cool
collectors tubs including a lot of
Marvel collectors tubs and recently they
released this really awesome stainless
steel shaker cup which does an excellent
job of keeping everything nice and cold
if you are an energy drink fan like me
you can use codecosmic gfuel.com to get
20 off everything and sometimes for new
Rivals and special orders thirty percent
off to check out their stuff just click
the link in the description down below
alright first things first the possible
release date for Spider-Man 4. Sony has
recently released a slate for their
upcoming movies they have released their
slate for 2023 and also some for 2024 on
this slate we see things like Spider-Man
across the spider-verse set for June 2nd
of this year 2023 we also have Craven
the hunter listed as well for October
6th of 2023 but then we have 2024 which
shows us El muerto which is coming
January 12th of 2024 Madam Webb which is
coming February 16th not too long after
Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse the
third Spider-Man animated film connected
to the other two of course coming out
March 29th 2024 if Garfield The Karate
Kid and then it lists an Untitled Sony
Slash Marvel Universe movie coming July
12 wealth of 2024 now it's very
interesting that all of these other
movies have their actual titles listed
but this one just says an Untitled movie
but it does specify that it is an MCU
film it takes place in the Marvel
Universe and really the only reason Sony
wouldn't exactly list this on their
slate is so people wouldn't know that
this is probably the release date for
Spider-Man 4. now some people have been
debating that this could be the slot for
Venom 3. however Venom typically
releases in October so it's most likely
going to stick true to that release date
October 2024 plus if it were Venom 3
they would most likely just State Venom
3 also Venom 3 does not take place as
far as we know in the MCU now of course
in the post credit for Venom Let There
Be Carnage Tom Hardy's Eddie Brock and
Venom did venture over into the MCU
however in the post credits for
Spider-Man no way home they went back to
the Sony spider-verse so we're not
really expecting Venom 3 to take place
in the MCU however we are expecting him
to go up against a Spider-Man most
likely Andrew Garfield Spider-Man but
we'll get to Venom 3 in just a bit now
Spider-Man homecoming and Spider-Man far
from home both had July release dates
Spider-man no way home had a December
release date because it had to fit
within the Marvel Studio schedule and
this kind of is the same but they
basically have more freedom with the
release date here because the studio
most likely wants it to come out before
the Kang Dynasty and Avengers Secret
Wars we have had some conflicting
reports that have said it might come out
between the two movies but that's just a
rumor for now this is an actual slate
released by Sony and of course it says
that it's subject to change and it very
well could however Sony is attending
cinemacon in April only two months away
and rumor has it that Tom Holland has
signed a new deal with Sony Marvel to
appear in six more films if this is true
then we should expect to hear some kind
of announcement about Spider-Man from
Sony in April now some people state that
this could possibly be another Sony
movie that takes place inside of the MCU
but I doubt it because we have haven't
heard anything about any other type of
film that Sony could produce that would
take place in the MCU and we all know
how good Sony is at keeping secrets I
mean it's not like we knew that Andrew
Garfield and Toby Maguire were gonna be
in Spider-Man no way home
that came out of you yeah you can't do
that huh no how on Earth
anyway we're getting sidetracked look so
we really doubt that this could be
another film that we don't know about
look going back to Venom 3 Tom Hardy has
officially posted an update about Venom
3 and it looks like production is about
to start soon Tom Hardy recently posted
on his Instagram that he is working on
Venom 3 pre-prep now what's interesting
is some people think that Venom 3 could
possibly come in 2025 however if Tom
Hardy is doing pre-prep and production
is about to begin then we are most
likely looking at in October of 2024
release date now like I mentioned before
if a July of 2024 release date is really
when Spider-Man 4 is coming out this
might give us a little bit of knowledge
on when Spider-Man 5 and Spider-Man 6
are going to come out typically Sony and
Marvel Studios have released the
Spider-Man films two years apart so if
Spider-Man 4 is coming in 2024 keep in
mind that would be before the Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars than Spider-Man
5 would come out after the Kang Dynasty
and Secret Wars in 2026 and if they
stick to the July release States
Spider-Man 5 could come out in July of
2024 that would be only two months after
Avengers Secret Wars comes out in May so
this could kind of be like what they did
after Avengers end game having
Spider-Man far from home pick up right
after the events of Avengers endgame and
address sort of what happened they could
do the same thing for Spider-Man 5. have
them address what happened in Avengers
Secret Wars in Spider-Man 5. then of
course if you're going to do two years
after that Spider-Man 6 would come in
2028 where we could see the introduction
of Miles Morales now like I mentioned we
have some news about Miles Morales on
two different fronts today according to
The Insider Jeff Snyder we are going to
see a live action Tom Holland in
Spider-Man across the spiderverse and
there's a rumor that goes with this that
Miles Morales could actually be going to
the MCU at some point in time during the
film now Tom Holland Spider-Man
appearing and across the spiderverse
just makes sense but the interesting
thing is that the report states he is
going to be in live action form what
does this necessarily mean for Miles
Morales well while the recent rumor
states that Miles could go to the MCU it
does state that when he does this or I
should say if he will still be in
animated form so I've heard some people
talking about this rumor and talking
about how we could possibly be getting a
first look at our live-action MCU Miles
Morales I do not think that is the case
I think this is simply going to be for
across the spider-verse and probably
just a Tom Holland Cameo whether he's
live action or not I do think it would
be cool to see Miles Morales go into the
MCU and just have one animated character
in a live-action universe but we'll have
to wait and see on that but there have
been a lot of reports and rumors
recently about a Miles Morales entering
the MCU possibly in Spider-Man 4 maybe 5
or 6 and after Spider-Man 6 when Tom
Holland has done a Spider-Man Miles
Morales will take over as the new
Spider-Man in the MCU well according to
The Insider film Odyssey Miles Morales
is not coming until after Avengers
Secret Wars now do I hope to see a
variant of Miles Morales and Secret Wars
absolutely and that very well could lead
to Tom Holland Spider-Man recognizing
Miles Morales in his Universe leading
him to take him on as a trainee
mentoring him along the way until
eventually he becomes the main
Spider-Man but since according to this
report he's not coming until after
Avengers Secret Wars we can hope that we
will get an introduction to him or at
least hopefully a tease in Spider-Man 5
which again could come not too long
after Avengers Secret Wars now the last
thing is a little bit of a clarification
about Tom Holland's role in Avengers
Kang Dynasty The Insider account my time
to shine hello stated a few days ago
that Tom Holland is going to be the lead
in Avengers King Dynasty this led many
people including myself to believe that
he was going to be the leader of the new
Avengers however she has recently
cleared up her report she recently
tweeted out I said lead not leader
meaning that Tom Holland's character is
going to be the lead character of
Avengers Kang Dynasty so this means that
Spider-Man man isn't necessarily the
leader of the new Avengers team simply
he is just one of the main characters of
the movie so for those hoping that Sam
Wilson's Captain America and Captain
Marvel will be the leader of the new
Avengers there is still hope for that
for y'all however I do still think that
Spider-Man will indeed be one of the
leaders of the new Avengers so leave all
of your thoughts and theories about all
of this news in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest Spider-Man news you can
always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf